good morning everyone
um welcome to legislative Administration
and time is 10 o'clock I'd like to open
the exact session and start
by asking rep Tierney since he's
standing to
lead us in the pledge
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and substance for all
people
thank you everyone
um we have three bills or two bills in
the cacr on our docket for today
um
hopefully we can have a spirited
discussion on
on these and see what it is we want to
accomplish
um
without
any hesitation
um I guess what I will do is bring up
cacr10 and
seek a
motion
um from rep constable
uh thank you Mr chair um I would move
um in expedient to legislate on cacr-10
rep Constable moves itl on cacr-10 do I
have a second
we have two seconds for a fourth
um
that being the case I wondered if rep
Kosovo would like to speak to his motion
uh briefly thank you Mr chair
um
you know
cacr-10 was
um as it's
changing the Constitution in order to
convenience some senators
and this committee really felt like the
bar was not reached to change the
constitution for the for that purpose
um we also felt like the
um unintended consequences weren't
really thought through on what it meant
for the house and for the governor and
and and and that so
um we felt it was the right thing to do
is to uh to kill it
thank you repressible
um any further discussion
I will just add the two dates in
question uh that are in the calendar at
present it really is a two days every
on the odd numbered years
for orientation and for inauguration
um
the Constitution doesn't require
attendance
so it would seem
a simple solution might be for the
Senate to
Simply decide who is going to attend one
and and who is going to attend the other
um it's not a requirement that the full
Senate attend
um
so it would seem to in order to
go through all of the time and expense
of changing the Constitution
which representative wall is quick to
point out correctly we should never
change the Constitution
um except for things that are serious
and and of a extreme nature
and and need to be done
um this is this would represent a a an
amendment
um and a cost to the taxpayers of New
Hampshire
in order to just simply
help with
with
the expense perhaps of of senators and
the inconvenience of the Senators to to
attend two days
um
so I uh for that reason I I concur with
the um the Ito motion and if there is no
further
conversation I will ask the clerk to
call the role by the way I want to thank
representative Micarta for filling in as
clerk today so
you get you get your first shot in here
so the clerk will call the roll
um sure
representative Sheehan yes
representative Osborne not present
representative Constable yes
yes representative house and that's not
representative Pearson absent clerk
votes yes
representative Tierney yes
representative wall yes
representative nutting Wong yes
representative turcott is absent
representative Richards absent
representative conlon absent
representative Dolan absent
representative Montiel
representative payer yeah yeah is that
how you say that okay
and the chair representative yes all
right so nine yes
no
no uh
any objection to consent calendar
seeing none you'll be on consent
okay representative
thank you Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion to retain SB 28.
uh rep McCarter moves retain on Senate
Bill 28
um is there a second
Ed by rep Tierney
foreign
Carter like to speak to her emotion I
would thank you Mr chair I don't see the
purpose of this bill being before this
committee at this time
um it's referenced in an RSA for the
joint legislative historical committee
the language grants them all of the uh
all of the authority to to approve or
deny application for making
um
requests for portraits in any of the
legislative buildings or prop or
Government properties so I don't see
um why this is even a bill why this is
before us at this time
thank you rep McCarter uh is there any
further discussion
yeah just because I'm new
um have other normally by the way
okay all right
have have other bills come through and
been approved for this sort of request
in the past and this is just normal that
they get this is how they're handled or
is this being handled consistently the
same from previous bills that have come
forward
uh
thank you for your question
um Can anyone answer the question
representative wall who serves on both
the joint legislative historical
committee and was Prior chair of
legislators
um and the question was whether other
bills have come through like this before
yes last year we had a bill come through
for uh directing The Joint historic
committee to consider accepting the
Wentworth cheswell bill and the only
reason we couldn't act on that is at
that time we had no likeness for that
portrait so we couldn't do it but in my
time in many years I don't remember
another bill coming by for a portrait
specifically there could have been but I
don't recall
thank you for that
um I will only add that yes it is true
that we had the um the request for a
likeness to be painted by um of
Wentworth cheswell last year the house
did act this committee did act
um positively the Senate chose to
change or amend the bill to a plaque
rather than a portrait for the reasons
that Senator that rep wall stated that
it was likeness was a problem
I don't recall to to go further I don't
recall at that time
us taking a look at the actual statutes
on the joint legislative historical
committee
um
if we had
if I had I think I would have been in
the same position that I'm in now so
so the the point of requesting a retain
now I think would have been the same it
had enough it has nothing to do with the
original title of the of the bill here
it has more to do with the overall
policy of is it is it correct that these
requests come to the legislative
Administration committee or is it
something if the plain reading of the
statute on the historical committee
appears like that request should go to
them directly
um
so that's part of the reason for the
retain I think in order to determine
um
what in the future what what that
process should be
you'll notice and I handed out a copy of
that statute you'll notice that under
17 Dash I colon 2 committee
responsibilities
um
under Roman V
it says to administer and enforce the
collections policy established by the
committee
I'm not sure what that is and I've asked
the chair and and no one seems to be
able to to um
provide that it also says that that
under still continuing under Roman 5
recommend legislation as needed to
implement this policy
um and then under Romans 7 it says to
provide guidelines to all branches of
state government relative to the
acquisition of historical cultural and
artistic objects
I don't know what that is
um I don't know what that guidance is
and and lastly under Roman nine it says
to be responsible for the placement of
portraits so that kind of takes away the
piece that was in the existing
legislation that says that this would be
put in the state house
um
I think that's where this needs to go
and I think
so so while I understand the their
request for
a portrait of um of the late Rogers
Johnson
I think we need to have further
information
before we proceed and I would think that
it's the perfect time for a uh for a
retained Motion in order to discuss this
over the summer with the joint
legislative historical committee which
as I pointed out rep
resentative wall serves on so um
I think it would be great representative
thank you Mr chairman I I agree with a
lot of what you have said
um in chapter law we already have
Title 1 chapter 4 section 9 defines
where we may Place portraits and other
memorabilia right but it doesn't
put that initial step into place
whatsoever and at one time we had the
New Hampshire Heritage collections
committee which oversaw all the
artifacts for the State of New Hampshire
the historic ones and um that committee
was Blended finally with the joint
history oh yeah with the joint historic
committee but
the wording from
the Heritage collection committee wasn't
necessarily Blended in adequately or at
all with the joint historic committee so
we need clarification on just exactly
what we will do and how thank you thank
you and I also wanted to point out that
the committee has received
some some research from our researcher
and in fact there's one page of it here
in front of you from an excerpt from the
Colorado's criteria and procedures for
the gift of loan of objects of Art and
memorials placed in the permanent or
temporary basis in the Colorado State
Capitol
I think this is what funnily enough we
were we were able to get the Colorado
version of what I think they're
referring to in our New Hampshire
statute under Roman five here I think
this is what we should be having
um and I think that it would be
beneficial if we don't have it for us to
be able to access uh what some of the
other states have done this is obviously
a a situation or a problem
that has arisen in a number of our state
houses across the country
dealing with space
at some point we need to get this policy
correct and and I think
the the very fine research that we were
able to put together so far would be
helpful for the for the people serving
on the joint legislative historical
Committee in order to
administer and enforce the collections
policy established by the committee if
they haven't already
so um representative netting Wong
[Music]
us portraits but I think for the bill
that's in front of us right now because
we can always file more legislation
later it's really important that we pass
this
um I think it's wrong to retain it at
this moment
um
I think that representation matters and
I've seen the difference it makes in
kids and adults when they see people
that look like them on the walls of
places or even just media
um and I think it's really important for
the kids that come in here and for the
rest of us to see the diversity that's
been in the house because I don't think
the state house as it is right now um
represents that
um so while I do think it's important
that maybe we I mean that we do figure
out some regulations I think the bill
right now as is should go forth
thank you
for the comments
go ahead representative well thank you I
do know one thing for sure and that is
that a portrait is not accepted or put
onto the walls unless the individual has
had significant
um and Irene really significant
contributions that they have made to the
state and to our government and we did
not hear testimony as to considerable
contributions
of this individual was an assistant
minority leader at one point but he also
did an awful lot for his community and
his County
as well as for his race and there has
been discussion outside the legislature
actually that
perhaps as people step back he had an
unfortunate death just this past year as
people step back and get a little more
perspective as a little bit of time goes
by because initially we all know you
shouldn't make big decisions right away
when we lose someone as much as we want
to that it may perhaps be appropriate to
have such a distinguished portrait
placed in a local he was from Stratham
and perhaps to have his portrait which
hasn't been painted yet
mounted in stratum in a location where a
lot of people would see it recognize it
remember him for what he did and honor
him more locally I'm not saying he
doesn't deserve to be here but I'm just
saying that if you look at the plaques
underneath the portraits we have now
um these individuals had longer term
bigger contributions to the state if I
may put it that way so I think we need
to I think we need to step back a little
bit before we move forward with this
thank you thank you I would also point
out
on the chance
that this collections policy does exist
and and will turn up later
um I would hate to move ahead
with the portrait
and find out that it violated any of the
collections policy that um
that already exists we don't we don't
really know that
um
and I also
understand yeah
I I know I knew and liked Rogers Johnson
um and I
I don't feel that we are dishonoring
um we're not saying no we're saying
um let's let's utilize this legislation
to make sure that we're on the right
side of any collections policy that's
already in statute that's that's my only
Point
um well not my only point but that's my
main point on on the uh on the statement
and I agree with what you've just said
that doesn't necessarily disqualify him
no
um but we do need to step back and look
at the big picture and we do need to
also recognize every time someone wants
to
donate a portrait
we're looking at the spaces that we have
in the State House complex for where we
can put these portraits we do have
limited space and
quite honestly it's getting crowded
we've had some concerns about where to
place more portraits we've moved things
around uh in the past couple years got
more order into which ones belong where
um and we need to determine some may be
better qualified to serve to be mounted
rather in the lob for example right and
then and it still didn't allow us to do
that right this bill was only specific
to the state house I believe it wasn't
her right
so so even that
um if we just take the point of the
existing legislation saying that the
portrait would be hung in the State
House
that would appear to have overstepped
our bounds under Roman nine that says
it's the duty of the joint legislative
historical committee to determine to be
responsible for the placement of
portraits Flags bus statutes or other
Memorial objects within or on
legislative facilities as defined by RSA
14 colon 14-b in consultation with the
division of historical Resources
Department of Natural and cultural
resources so just on that one simple
thing it sounds like
um the legislation as it stands in front
of us would need to be amended anyway
so for that reason I I think
I think we've beat this up pretty good
um
is there any further discussion or I
will ask Clark to call the roll
where where
we're voting on Senate Bill 28 just to
re remind everyone Senate Bill 28 to
retain
um
and I'll ask the clerk call the roll
representative Sheehan yes
representative Osborne's absent
representative Constable yes
yes representative Hobson's absent
representative Pearson is absent the
clerk votes yes
representative Tierney yes
representative wall yes representative
nutting Wong no
representative turcott is absent
representative Richards is absent
representative Colin is absent
representative Dolan is absent
representative Montiel is absent
oh no I'm sorry I'm sorry
sorry
okay uh representative payer yeah
okay seven year one day
me oh yeah you representative Hill yes
thank you eight
uh the vote being 18 yes one no eight
I'm sorry eight yes one no
um the motion to retain passes
and we are done with Senate bill 28.
um
they don't go on the calendar
so yes you can put it on your consent
but it doesn't go anywhere
um
with that I will open the the exact
session on Senate bill 84. which is
relative to legislative study committees
and commissions
and I would recognize a motion from our
vice chair representative Sheehan
um yes I'd like to move to retain Senate
Bill 84. representative Sheehan moves
retain on Senate Bill 84 uh is there a
second well second
seconded by representative McCarter
would representative Sheehan like to
speak to her motion to retain yes thank
you Mr chair
um the speaker has established a special
committee on commissions and we've been
meeting and
um the legislation that we create in
this special committee will be amended
into SB 84 so that's why we're retaining
it so it can be used with the findings
and the work that we come up with in
this special committee on commissions
thank you representative she and Is
there further discussion
I will just say
um I'm not entirely certain
and I'm not sure it's been determined
the process for how this special
committee on
committee on committees is going to
operate or if their their process will
will involve legislative Administration
even
um
this this seems to be the bill that
would be used and it seems to be the
most logical bill for us to um to hang
on to for that purpose if it's necessary
if it's not we'll simply
deal with it in November in our in our
meeting and then it will go to the Full
House in January
um
any further questions comments concerns
seeing none
I will ask the clerk to call a roll
we're voting on Senate Bill 84
with the motion to retain
representative Sheehan yes
representative Osmond's absent
representative Constable yes
representative Hobson's absent
representative Pearson's absent clerk
votes yes representative Tierney yes
representative wall yes
representative nutting Wong yes
representative turcotte is absent
representative Richards is absent
representative Conlin is absent
representative Dolan is absent
representative Montiel yeah
representative prior
and chairman Hill
yes
it only took one I know
uh with a vote of yes
uh nine and no Nays
um the motion to retain passes
and with that I think we are closed with
our work for today
um Senate Bill 84 actually we're closed
for our work
for this half of the year I do have a
couple of comments but representative
wall quick question so all of these are
on consent is that accurate no
um the only first the cacr will be on
consent retain oh that's right I'm sorry
it's been a long time I apologize no
that's fine it's good good reminder for
everyone
um
we do have uh I think we're at three or
four
three retained bills correct yes
um
the speaker has announced that we would
be able to Begin work on retained bills
in June
um
that doesn't mean we have to begin in
June we have until November uh to file a
report on these so uh it is my intention
in the over the next week or so and I'll
probably uh talk to a few people during
session on Thursday
um
I'm leaning towards making these uh
a few subcommittees rather than
Committee of the whole
um there may be a need for the
subcommittee especially on the bill for
ethics
to have some conversation with um
the Ethics Committee it's been difficult
in the past to schedule things with the
Ethics Committee and especially when we
have a full Committee of the whole
schedule so perhaps if we can get a
subcommittee together to um to have a
conversation with the Ethics Committee
um come up with some ideas and then that
subcommittee bring them to the committee
as a whole
um that that's seems to be my procedure
I'm I'm happy to entertain any other
thoughts on that but um
these other two that we have retained
today
um
Senate Bill 84 I don't think we need to
form a subcommittee we we pretty much
have a subcommittee installed in the in
the other special committee on uh on
study committees
and we
and as far as the the bill we just
discussed regarding the joint historical
committee
that I think we we will form a
subcommittee for
um and let them come up with how or if
we need to proceed
representative wall thank you Mr
chairman um The Joint historic committee
has not scheduled its next meeting but I
I believe it's worth to bring this issue
up and and get that right out on the
table and not table it get it on the
table for discussion and see where we
can get with that to help this out thank
you uh thank you representative would it
be possible since you serve on both
um
for you to get us on the agenda for that
um that I'm the vice chairman yes
well then I'll expect to be first or
second on that list after the after the
Pledge of Allegiance
um
I would think
it it is a topic that that needs to come
up and needs to be discussed and um and
if you would let us know when that
exists I will certainly
be in attendance and I would think
um we need to have a discussion about uh
who what which members of the of
legislative Administration would serve
on a subcommittee if if such a thing
would need to be placed
um
that's all I have for now uh the plan we
don't have anything
um
moving forward in the Senate so we don't
have to deal with anything that maybe a
an amended version in the Senate so all
of the Committees of conference is a
non-issue for this committee you can
applaud now if you'd like
it is um
that does not mean that uh if for those
of you that serve on other committees
that you won't be called for a committee
of conference there
um I think
um we've done
our job
um as cleanly and as efficiently as we
possibly could
um I think we're in pretty good shape
um moving into the summer but um
I would only ask that if you receive or
look for a note from our
our vice chair if there is questions on
setting up subcommittees and who would
who would be willing to serve if there
are subcommittees specifically you would
like to be on please let us know
um that would be a great help as you can
see attendance is is spotty and we
already have a shorter staffed committee
as it is so the more volunteerism the
better as far as I'm concerned
with that I am done is there any
questions comments uh concerns that we
need to handle before we close business
for today
yes representative wall I I have a
question of Representative Alison
nutting Wong if I may please uh I know I
just know what your belief on uh CAC or
excuse me SB 28 do you think you might
want to speak to that on the floor and
pull it off consent or not okay just to
be sure it's not on consent yeah thank
you very much sure
good point thank you
um I think we're set uh is there one
last thing I want to thank publicly our
researcher
um uh for giving us the information
that solidified excuse me my point of
view anyway on this historic committee
I would um
I would like to know if there's anything
in order to give her as much time as
possible if there's anything that you
all think would be important for any
subcommittee work
I tried
um
great
all right with that I'll adjourn thank
you very much everyone